we're almost there violet just hang on
he's coming
[Music]
how many genre movies can you think of
with lgbt characters playing the heroes
in the 1990s asked herself that exact
question
i'm racking my brain and i can't think
of one
lana had this revelation after watching
the silence of the lambs in theaters
which despite being an artistic triumph
follows a long line of films like psycho
dress to kill and sleepway camp where
trans or gender fluid characters are not
only the villains but actually deranged
psycho killers
there have been sympathetic queer
characters especially in more recent
films but the films almost always fit
into one
of two categories either they're
lighthearted comedies or their total
downers but the wachowskis wanted to do
something different
they wanted to make a movie with
sympathetic queer characters that was a
genre movie first
it would star a lesbian couple while
still delivering the suspense and action
of a classic noir film in the 1990s that
had never been done before in a
mainstream film
but lana wachowski and her sister lily
did exactly that when they wrote and
directed bound
the greatest lesbian gangster heist
movie ever made and i was just like
in 1994 the wachowski sold two of their
scripts to warner brothers
the first was bound and the second was
another film they also wanted to direct
the studio didn't trust them to direct
the second film because it was much more
expensive
so they made bound first which gave the
studio the confidence to let them direct
their second film a big budget sci-fi
with lots of fight scenes and special
effects
you may have heard of it do you know
what i'm talking about
the matrix the matrix contains many now
iconic techniques but bound did a lot of
them first
just on a smaller scale in fact bound
has an early version of the now famous
360 shot and it has bullets in slow
motion
there's a terrific shot of the bullet
flying through the air
if you look at it carefully you can
actually see the piece of lead in a
very simple and formative way that's the
origins of bullet time
all the major crew for the matrix first
collaborated together on bound
including the editor cinematographer
composer and sound designer and once you
explore
bound's incredible understanding of
genre filmmaking techniques and
character development it's no surprise
that this creative team would go on to
make a film as influential as the matrix
bound stars two women corki a butch
lesbian who just got out of prison and
violet a more feminine woman who's
dating caesar a money launderer for the
mob
the story revolves around the two women
becoming lovers and hatching a plan to
steal two million dollars from caesar
and the mafia their heist
starts off as planned corki steals the
money and hides it in the apartment next
door
once caesar finds out the money is
stolen they expect him to run away but
he
instead stays put and tries to convince
the mafia that he didn't take the money
from here the plan spirals out of
control in an homage to classic black
and white noir films many of the shots
in the film look almost completely black
and white and cinematographer bill pope
employed film techniques popular in the
1950s such as high contrast and
unbalanced composition to create a sense
of unease
as caesar tries to find the stolen money
his lighting gets more and more extreme
showing his gradual descent into madness
such extreme lighting techniques were
common in old noir movies like double
indemnity and the maltese falcon
along with the noir visuals the story
also has noir elements including an
intricate plot a looming sense of doom
and deceptive
morally ambiguous characters violet
embodies the femme fatale
a noir character who uses her beauty to
seduce and manipulate unsuspecting men
when talking to men
violet raises the pitch of her voice to
appear more delicate and helpless and
even corky is initially suspicious
of her flirtation all these tropes
inbound show the wachowski's
understanding of
genre but where the film truly shines is
not in its recreation of past genres but
in how it builds on top of them and
creates something completely new
the film does use monochromatic lighting
like old black and white films but it's
when it breaks that rule that the film
gets created
oh my god don't worry they might
with such a desaturated film the
wachowskis use color to make things
stand out
color most often emphasizes the bloody
violence but it also makes johnny's
cartoonish suit stand out
showing his immaturity in the scene
where violet seduces corki her purple
lipstick is often the only color in the
shot
which draws attention to her sexuality
in the same way that color challenges
the visual design of noir
violet's character plays with the
expectations of the femme fatale the
femme fatale typically turns on the main
character while corki and violet plan
the heist we still don't know for sure
if we can trust violet had a partner
once
she [ __ ] me the wachowskis used the
expected betrayal of the femme fatale to
raise the tension but in the end
violet doesn't do what we expected
instead we get to see a noir film where
we actually root for the femme fatale
rather than fear her
it totally flips the genre on its head
this time the male gangster is the
antagonist and the femme fatale is the
protagonist in previous noirs the femme
fatale tricks the main character as well
as the audience but in bound the
audience is
in on the deception since we know violet
and corki's plan from the beginning
this shift in perspective creates a film
full of dramatic irony and tension
because we know everything about the
heist even if all the male characters
don't have a clue
from the beginning the women are in
control of both the frame and the story
when corki and violet first meet in the
elevator they clearly check each other
out but all that flirting literally
happens behind caesar's back
unlike in most genre films the
wachowskis wanted to make violet
a calm calculated heroine they even had
to reshoot an entire scene to make sure
they didn't portray her as
stereotypically frantic or over the top
i thought this would be a really good
place for violet to reveal all the anger
that she had percolating below the
surface
but i was wrong it would have been great
if it was a scorsese picture but this is
not a scorsese picture so i understand
why they want to reshoot it
violet's predicament inbound actually
has a lot in common with the predicament
of karen in martin scorsese's film
goodfellas both characters are trapped
in a relationship with a guy who works
for the mafia both films have a similar
scene where the woman has the
opportunity to shoot her man
but they turn out quite differently the
goodfellas scene follows the tradition
of many noir films like the maltese
falcon the killers and double
indemnity where the women act frantic
and unheroic and their fight against men
feels desperate
now i won't spoil exactly how this scene
inbound ends but let's just say that
violet doesn't have that problem
caesar you don't know [ __ ] i love this
line because it almost feels like violet
is addressing the audience
like caesar we had expectations for how
this film would play out we expected
violet would betray corki we expected
caesar would keep his cool and we
expected the women to be the victims
but like caesar we got tricked bound
toying with genre in refreshing ways is
enough to make it a classic but another
element of the film
elevates it to the greatest lesbian
gangster heist movie ever made
wait
i don't think so bound is one of the
first
if not the first mainstream genre movie
starring a sympathetic lesbian couple
and the wachowskis hired lesbian author
and critic susie bright to help them
execute this concept in an authentic way
together they changed how
movies portray sex both literally and
symbolically
by focusing on the feminine aspects of
sex this movie is so
wet this kind of style you know gangster
movies everything's about a hard-on
everything's about being hard and this
movie was just
wet dripping wet all the time
inbound the hand represents sex a
concept that according to bright
resonated with the lesbian community the
hands are the sex organs in this
and every lesbian understood that who
saw the movie
so for the first time in a war flick the
wachowskis have a brand new symbol
at their disposal the hand becomes a sex
object hands unite the two characters
and symbolize corky and violet's
connection when caesar threatens to cut
off violet's fingers it's a form of
castration the film
shows sexuality in a distinctly lesbian
way especially in how corky and violet
present themselves
corki is the masculine butch lesbian and
violet is the girly femme
playing into those stereotypes leads to
some of the humor in the film like when
violet correctly guesses that corki is
good with her hands
i'll bet your car is 20 years old truck
truck of course 63 chevy
i knew it but the film never reduces the
two lesbians to caricature in fact the
two frequently break their stereotypes
when violet is alone with corki she
downplays her fem side lowering her
pitch
and wearing jeans instead of a dress and
violet isn't the innocent
curious woman seduced by the more
confident lesbian it's the exact
opposite
even caesar breaks from the expectations
of a typical gangster
he's actually one of the more feminine
characters in the film instead of the
woman getting jealous like in goodfellas
caesar is the one who hates that johnny
flirts with violet
of all the characters he's the most
hysterical and he even looks like a
housewife when he puts on a smock and
irons all the money
by playing with the expected roles of
violet corki and caesar the wachowskis
create
a brand new story while still delivering
the thrills of a conventional noir
the film received praise not just for
its brand new plot but also for its
brand new portrayal of lesbians
i'm just here to get laid
[Music]
at the time the wachowskis made bound
films about gay characters almost always
showed them either ashamed or uncertain
of their sexuality
and that's a trend that continues to
this day but violet and corki break that
trend by not regretting their sex at all
it's one thing i can't stand is women
who apologize for wanting sex
the film's unabashedly gay story
combined with its clear understanding of
lesbian culture
led to many in the queer community
embracing the film it was shown in the
castro theater
and it was filled with lesbians when the
movie was over
the entire theater was pounding on the
floor with their feet
the theater was literally literally
rocking
i mean it was moving i've seen the power
of this film first hand
i recommended it to a friend who ended
up loving it so much she got a tattoo of
violet on her arm
she even included a labyrinth the same
object corki has tattooed on her
arm which symbolizes the matriarchy the
symbol suits this film quite well
because corki and violet both overcome
the usual boundaries set on women in
noir and gangster films
corki crosses that boundary by playing a
role typically given to a man and violet
crosses that boundary by defying the
expectations of the femme fatale
i've got stacks of letters from femmes
all over the country saying
it is so great to see a woman who they
think she's going to be the fatale and
they think she's going to betray
and let go and she ends up being so
competent and so real and so reliable
you never get to see a reliable femme in
this
kind of movie so it was just it was a
great day for womankind
bound just goes to show that you don't
need to sacrifice the thrills of a genre
film to include women and lgbt people in
your story
on the contrary those identities can
make your film more interesting because
they give the filmmaker an opportunity
to push the boundaries of what could
happen in a noir
gangster or heist film ew bound
challenges the established rules of
genre films so it's no surprise that the
film itself is about breaking rules and
crossing boundaries
in the film caesar tries to create
boundaries by preventing things from
entering and exiting his apartment he
doesn't let violet leave while they
torture shelley and he tries to keep
johnny quiet to prevent sound from
escaping he's making too much noise
he even attempts to control corki early
on he forces her to accept some money so
he can keep her
under his thumb but despite all his best
efforts the boundaries of his apartment
are fluid
corki can hear through the walls and
violet allows her to enter and
exit freely one of the coolest examples
of fluid boundaries is when violet and
corki make their plan to steal the
mafia's money
and instead of cutting between two
locations corki appears like an
apparition in violet's apartment to talk
through the plan
come to my place in the morning so it's
only appropriate that caesar realizes
something is up by hearing a phone ring
through his walls he gets a literal
wake-up call that the boundaries of his
apartment aren't as secure as he thought
but the boundaries don't stop
violet and corky even with a wall
separating them they still connect
in the end the use of genre the
characters and the story
all cross boundaries so if you're
wondering why the film is called
bound that's why the title of the film
does a great job of showing the multiple
ideas expressed in the film
the most obvious meaning of bound is to
be restricted like when corki is bound
by rope in the opening of the film
but the promotional art for the film
clearly shows that being bound with rope
also has sexual connotations echoing the
non-traditional lesbian relationship
at the center of the story but if you
want to go even deeper bound also means
certain to do something corky and violet
are bound to escape their predicaments
and follow their destiny
and this is a story not bound to genre
rules and also not bound to conventional
sexual and gender identities and even
the wachowskis themselves have crossed
boundaries
years after bound came out both
wachowskis came out as trans women which
adds another layer of meaning to their
early work
with their coming out as trans bounds
positive representation of the lgbt
community feels that much more personal
and like the matrix both films deserve
close readings with a transgender lens
for example both films have a moment
where one person thinks
another character is a man but that
character is actually a woman
in the matrix neo assumes trinity will
be a man i just thought um
[Music]
you were a guy and in bound caesar
assumes violet is hooking up with a guy
but it turns out she's with a woman i
thought
[ __ ] dark in here in so many ways the
wachowskis susie bright and the rest of
the production team
made a film that escaped the bounds of
what a genre movie can be
so if you haven't watched this film all
i ask is that you give it a shot
because i have a feeling you'll enjoy
watching the greatest lesbian gangster
heist movie ever
[Music]
the wachowski's first director of
photography for bount actually dropped
out
because he didn't think he could make
their film with their budget in the end
bill pope signed on and helped them
execute their vision on a shoestring
budget it's a
great movie made for nothing to me is a
perfect little gym but these days you
don't need an
agent or production company to learn how
to shoot video on a lower budget
to do that you can watch christopher
rhode's class on that exact topic where
he goes in depth on how to maximize your
budget for a video project
you can watch that class and thousands
more by getting a free trial of the
skillshare premium membership
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
including classes on photography content
creation and video editing
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity with
skillshare you can be like the
wachowskis and make your creative vision
a reality
click on the link in the description to
explore your creativity and the first 1
000 people to use our link will get a
free trial of skillshare premium
membership
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video and a big thanks to my patreon
supporters who make this channel
possible
there's a new podcast episode ready for
all the five dollar patrons
thanks for watching
you